hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to deputy dangle I am still
loopy out of my mind on cold medicine in
fact I just took another dose a little
bit ago and I'm ready to play another
game because I have a duty and
obligation to Brydon you guys with
entertainment and I'm more than happy to
do that but this game was recommended to
me by you guys and I was looking at
other controls here if I have to control
this guy by his arms and legs Allah
Octodad I might lose my mind or I might
find it absolutely hilarious and it's
said that it needs a joypad thing it's
not broken it's just a little damaged I
put it back together I'm okay so let's
get to it
morning dangle I'm Chong go do this just
got a tip this Amole was your Rabobank
funny right
anyway I'm just gonna grab my Crocs more
with my low key then pull the bun the
corresponds to the limb am I actually
doing this no I'm not oh also its
Octodad but I have even less control
over my body that's good this is gonna
be fantastic I can already tell okay I
get it
I'll learn on the fly but this time oh
oh that is dangly oh that is goopy
that's the bike alarm no that's a bake
hello old lady man you look exactly like
oh my god what was the movie mastermind
ah Megamind and the tip was real dangle
we need to stop go catch your dangle
it's your time to shine
thanks grundle who's your name Grimlock
I only uh hey kid how you doing but when
the mega mine turned into the old man to
be the dad of the guy if you haven't
seen the movie see it's rather charming
and pretty cool but not the best
animation ever oh my goodness am i
Steven supposed to try to walk God was
everything trying to be turbo dismount
in 3d yeah come back here lady
my name is lieutenant dangle deputy
dangle I guess oh no not a banana
what okay oh okay
Chango that was your name she got away
my animus right we need to check out
that crash okay I'm on my way
Debbie do dangle on the job Secret
Service Michael's guard everybody hello
baby hey oh hey hey how you doing
wait no go away you got dead eyes oh my
god
she had dolls eyes oh my god ah there's
something on your phone okay bye she's
gonna warn you about the giant sausage
on your face hey I'm coming chongo don't
rush deputy dangle Secret Service agent
Michael Scarn yep any minute now it's
hard to tell what's up sweet little is
she kids I could have been killed
quickly we're gonna get it back into
truth before they water it wow those are
some fat cats uh
alright then how am i how am i how do
you expect me to actually do this you
okay alright come here cats and yeah oh
my he'll probably come on Drago too
slippery for you
shut up Chango oh oh why is that there
where there pumping oil in the middle of
a residential area okay I guess I'm
gonna get sticky so that all these
little Pussycats can oh my god I'm an
eco-disaster right now hot dog guy
alright y'all just gone down now okay's
I'm gonna slap you on the body and it's
gonna be feel good it's gonna be feel
good what is happening with my life oh
my god okay I get it
come here ha ha stick yeah how about
stick your good no no no no no no no I
can't get away from often there's a
lieutenant W detangle hey wait do I have
five on me I think only four come here
honey come
don't you run away from dangle where'd
you go don't you run away from dangle a
little pretty kitty I find it's best to
alternate one arm and leg at a time cuz
apparently that's what needs me I'm
pretty sure one of the buttons is
controlling my crotch and I just thrust
myself towards these cats how their gosh
no I know you don't hate I dug it yeah
get back here it sticks to my body oh I
do have 500k maybe that's why Natalie
returned these is obviously that's the
worst I'm actually weirdly getting the
hang of these controls faster than any
other weird physics game I've ever
played it's something strange yay Gogol
I love kids you know but I'm
strawberry's chamber ever okay then so
what's your point he's going going ditch
donut cuz we're a walking cliche all
right Tom go where you going Chango stop
dragging your huge knuckle okay well
outside oh you're feeling why would you
get cleaned up with all order the donuts
there's a vlogger down that alley you
can yeah back alley faucet then I'm
gonna get clean with thanks Sean go
you're just the best
superior officer away this isn't a think
oh this is the garbage why why why dog
no oh my god how why why would there be
a sink back here it's a dog oh that's
what I'm it wasn't a singer
yay I'm all better now
oh it's not a dog is it that's a goddamn
Ram oh god oh god that's terrifying
ah you want to mess with dango no no
look like a dog to go what the hell
dog we go you're gonna have to climb
over lose weight lose brave angle can
climb almost anything in the game that's
good to know
that's very useful for my everyday life
I'm not okay
okay he's left some dignity lib green
ring okay then so it is turd turbo blegh
and Hobbit I don't remember what it is
now your friend sorry my brain is not
working today I hope you can forgive me
for my transgressions I'm this weirdly
intuitive not this right now but God
this I never mind I'm not gonna get this
kid never be yeah okay so stick okay so
all I got oh okay well I was doing it
wrong before all I gotta do is get it on
there and then let go and it'll go so I
can ah look at that look at that look at
that look at that Leela is the thing of
beauty
Hey nope stop that stop just there we go
up sweating yourself over and then let
go of that way oh yeah you jiggle push a
donor's day you figure out gets that
grandma robber or more probably here
with my big Popeye forearms if I know
what's good for me I do know what's good
with
your nose ring won't wake up the dollars
on the white bag Wow okay let's double
units we have a 4-3-3 5j r 3 T 4 JCP
flyer where the 4 3 3 5 JP 3 C 4 T P is
in progress of 1 2 3 swanky Dr Who - coy
glory equation yo we got help
Chango to rescue well it's too bad that
I'm not near the faucet that I was just
at door a Chung go I'm on my way I'm
gonna move my legs in a lyrical fashion
such dawn I'm gonna let go this - I'll
cover for you
I'm coming for you hey little good lucy
a magic bag ok do I go we go help
loading she should be wrong with water
tower why everyone wrong let the robber
grandma you're gonna die Oh what in the
world a ghost that's normal come on I
okay so now the buildings on fire and
haunted I didn't jump what to work on Oh
God
this even possess process okay hold it a
very good situation what in the world
get up all the room leave you visual
okay so what was the point of the robber
making a ghost cop cuz I'm pretty sure
that's what that was I mean we already
had a thorough discussion on ghost cops
powers and abilities when we did that
Diablo 3 thing with like me jontron Oh
God okay so I need to dodge that this is
not gonna be easy as oh god oh god oh
god oh you think you can mess with me
look at it angles coming for you baby
coming for you baby
I'm gonna possess that goes right
are you up nope uh-huh not Avenue I'm
good at this game for some real reason
wait nope
okay maybe not maybe not how do I get in
there yeah all right
oh I need to get to the roof I don't
need to go in there sorry my bad my
mistake okay let go of that one okay all
right sorry it's got in the win over yep
let go of that one wet all right there
we go okay yep how about skip yeah the
tearling get bulky yeah there we go
there we go I can't wait for them jelly
doughnuts yeah I've been working real
hard climbing our roof ain't too easy
now don't run off don't know I turned
either Wisconsin or Canadian well don't
go ever you know second ad intern fine
this one the world the tnt water bomb
okay I guess I shouldn't be worried
about how the laws of physics babies
game you're gonna go white guy go
forwards y'all how do I get on the
ground I was on the roof build a super
awesome device retrieved the one okay
then can I stop in the foon bow my
goodness I have become really slippery
yep
okay da da da yeah yeah good come on
retrieve the plunger I have goodbye
glassing right at all yeah oh yeah
ha ha ha Wow is the gun in a school yard
so what I'm about to discover here yup
there's this gun oh it is it's in the
middle of a school yard I'm pretty sure
this is school and I'm pretty sure that
that's a blood stain southern [ __ ]
was happening in this neighborhood of
happy-go-lucky fun retrieve the road I'm
gonna get oh I know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna build a plunger launcher I can
already tell that's what's gonna happen
cuz I need the rope I got the plunger
and I'm gonna get on that plane and I'm
gonna save the day cuz I'm deputy dangle
oh yeah like what I going what am i
doing hey brain bear is man it Mugen
stop grabbing on to that don't don't
need to do that why is this happening
what why why why I must dance I must
dance there's the Rope I gotcha what you
have acquired the plunger gun I'm glad
you have a porta potti there for
reference to know what plungers are for
not for porta-potties boom hey that's
awesome
that's only could be useful I'm gonna
get on that plane sucker and I'm gonna
do it from the place that you want okay
at you okay that you okay that you
launched from ah cuz I'm a madman who
vengeance is a lot yeah you may gonna
suck Oh Peter you make it a sweeping
motion with your plane fader I got a
plunger gun I don't know if this is
gonna work Bader hey hey hey
Hey
ah what down dammit I gotta like Vader I
got some dog destroy the propellers how
am I supposed to do that
what in the world are you kidding me I'm
gonna fall off this damn plane
yeah yeah Bucci yeah what's the point I
did exactly what I said I wouldn't do
hey hater I got back on the plane that
was really epic I'm not gonna lie how's
awesome
oh yes Sam Bader I'm coming for you old
lady
yeah okay Wow okay here we go
lucky Wow miss all right I missed I
missed I missed I missed come on come on
baby
let me do it again let me down again ah
Oh what the hell am i over there now it
was over in the okay well this happening
now I don't want to go up dammit you
there we go now I'm underneath it at
least I can do some here yeah yep okay
those birds just picked a toast
Wow sad got such a hero oh I do just
throw myself into there ah yeah take
that my rock hard rubber body you can't
handle no to this old lady actually you
probably can't you'd break it oh no
wrong way
nope nope wrong way this camera is not
good okay
okay all right there we go this is a
toughie my god no no no no no don't go
under under god no I can't control where
it goes it just goes up and forward No
god bless america
humming if i crab-walk my way over
something will happen there we go
crab walk crab crab crab it grab it grab
it grab it just why isn't it going up
now there we go god this is this really
really really fro okay now I'm up here
now just oh boy there we go God you got
it got it come on there we go good God
that took way too long he'll never catch
me dangle Oh what where did this come
from
what in the world okay now are we back
to having fun
yay whoa did I just burn honey am I like
T of two characters and that I'm
propelling my car on money okay
he's only attended and active City
listen and not entirely for monetary
reward
yeah now that part that part there was
messed up it was not okay but now we're
back into it now I can be a little less
grip
I'm just luckily hitting all the money
on that entirely okay well okay shiznit
come here grandma run you right over
what what what happened what's going on
oh that's will give us cold medicine
I'm not okay uh borrowed Idol okay this
goddamn solo lady was gonna rob bike 40
right
anyway I'm hungry let's go get some
donuts oh-ho what wait a minute no no no
no no no I know this was just a demo but
is how this ends okay I guess that's the
end of the demo you can play this game
for yourself I bet those other things to
explore this link down the description
and heck this is gonna be a pretty good
game I mean there just needs to be some
tweaking of some things I know it's
meant to be frustrating controls but I
was actually able to do it just fine up
until that plane point when the wind was
blowing me is really frustrating but
either way it's a fun game it's free for
the demo right now and I'm sure that the
final game won't cost too much maybe 10
20 bucks so anyway thank you all so much
for watching support the developers
click the description down below there's
a link for other awesome games that I
played in the past or the annotation
over there watch some more there are a
lot of fun thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
come on the fear affect me I'm a
beheaded